hello everyone and welcome to another
stockfish versus alpha zero game and
this match became so popular in the past
week that people and I'm pretty sure
people want to see alpha play stockfish
more than they would enjoy a World Chess
Championship match and so far I've done
six videos this is video number seven I
will probably do all 10 videos maybe one
of vs. talk first game per day but so
far we've seen five games where alpha is
white and only one game where alpha is
black and in the games that alpha zero
had the white piece of stock fish always
defended with the queen's indian defense
and alpha destroyed the queen's indian
defense and here we have a second game
where alpha 0 plays with the black
pieces and again as doctors goes for
efore and alpha defense with the berlin
defense
so it's what is alpha saying here is the
queen's indian dead and his efore in
general are refuted opening you know I
always say but the Berlin defense was
used to to deprive Gary Kasparov of his
World Championship title and you know he
couldn't win a single game against the
Berlin defense so maybe maybe there is
something to it even after Kasparov lost
the World Chess Championship match
against Kramnik he was still for a long
time by far the strongest player in the
world but the Berlin defence against
efore seems to be all powerful so let's
see this game stockfish again opens with
e4 e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 there
should be 5 Derulo PES we have 90 to f6
now the Berlin defense d3 and the Bishop
to c5 as Dogfish captures the knight
Bishop captures D captures and here we
have castles Knight to d7 and to this
point the moves are exactly the same as
in the previous game I shown where alpha
had the black pieces but here instead of
Knight B to d2 stockfish goes for c3 we
have a castles by alpha D for Bishop to
d6 now protecting d5 pawn Bishop to g5
would attempt on the Queen Queen e8 and
rook to e1 and here we have f6 Bishop to
h4 Queen to f7 now Nightbeat
d two and A five preparing perhaps an
expansion on the Queen side and also
stopping white from expanding himself on
the Queen side Bishop the g3 rook to e8
and Queen to c2 knife to f8 now c4 and
c5 and the d5 was played you don't want
to capture here there's really no point
to this you only make alphas the dark
square Bishop come alive so C 4 D 5
closing the center and B 6 now Knight to
h4 now g6 stopping any night at 5 ideas
in the future and maybe preparing to
push f5 knight back but H back to f3
Bishop to d7 rook a to d1 and as you can
see see it's a pretty close position in
the previous game where alpha defendant
with a brilliant defense sawfish went
for an early night sacrifice he said he
sacrificed a night for two central pawns
and alpha very quickly refuted this but
here it's a it's equal material and it's
pretty close position where alpha has
the bishop pair but in such a close
position the bishop pair isn't really
useful here alphas Bishop on d6 is more
like a pawn rook to e6
we have h3 now Queen to g7 Queen to c3
rook 88-83 h6 Bishop to h4 now and here
is a couple of interesting maneuvers
stockfish played Bishop to h4 stopping
alpha from pushing f5 and alpha place
rook to f7 now sawfish repeats Bishop to
g3 and Alpha repeats rook to e7
stockfish repeats again rook to h4 rope
to f7 again by alpha and erupted bishop
to g3
again by stockfish and if alpha plays
rook F to e7 again it's a draw by
threefold repetition so here alpha
refuses the draw place a for okay King
to h1 and now rook F back to e7 so we
have Bishop to h4 again
rook to f7 again bishop the g3 rook to
f7 a rook F to e7 again
Bishop to h4 again and
here again stock fish is interested in a
draw if alpha would repeat rook to f7
but again for the second time alpha
refuses the draw and plays g5 and this
is what's interesting is is alpha simply
refusing the draw or does it consider
now after it repeated to move two times
that for the third time maybe it learned
that the that this next variation could
lead to a win or does it always have a
draw in the pocket so to say and simply
tries to win the game
that's very interesting Bishop to g3 and
now Knight to g6 controlling f4 and h4
92 f1 rope to f7 now and the 933 now
stockfish again guards f5 Knight to e7
and it's interesting here for example
it's very hard to imagine how how do you
make progress with black here again look
at this bishop on d6 it's it's exactly
like a pawn but here alpha really really
tries to revive this Bishop and it's
it's a work of art how alpha does it so
nice to e7 Queen to d3 now H 5 H 4 and
Knight to c8 now rook to e 2g 4/9 to d2
and here we have Queen to h7 and in the
past six moves what alpha has done now
the bishop has a path Bishop to f8 to h6
and from h6 it will be a very powerful
piece so you know that's some that's
some maneuvering king to g1 Bishop to f8
now right the b1 Knight to d6 now
getting this night to a more active
square pressuring b4 and c4 and d4
Knight to c3 and now go to h6 and now
instead of a dead Bishop on d6 now alpha
has this beautiful light square bishop
and this beautiful dark square Bishop
slicing the position rook to f1 rook to
e8 perhaps perhaps going defending this
pawn so maybe the light square bishop
can move now King to H 2 into f8 King to
g1 back into g 6f 4 and here
she captures on f4 Ambus on rock actors
on f3 and Bishop captures on e3 and this
is a very interesting position probably
probably alpha doesn't want to allow
Knight to a5 for a force dogfish to play
but it's interesting do you do give up
the dark square bishop or or don't you
so okay Bishop captures on III rook
captures on e3 and now King to e7 Bishop
to e1 Queen to h7 roof to g3 and rook
the g7 now here alpha goes for a series
of exchanges rope to g7 King Queen
captures on g7 and rook to e3 preparing
the rook g3 rogue g8 rocked the g3 now
exchanging another set of rooks Queen to
h8 nice to be one now rook captures
Bishop captures and Queen to h6 night
the d2 Bishop to g4 now this from a
position where alpha had that terrible
Bishop on d6 and now it has a beautiful
Bishop on g4 and this dark square bishop
that stockfish has it's it's not doing
much it's pretty much boxed in it's very
hard for it to enter the position it
couldn't even if it tried even if Bishop
II 1 - D - even if it gets to h6 there's
really nothing for it to do one h6 so
king h2 King d7 b 3 now a capture some
b3 night capture some b3 and queen to g6
again preparing f5 night to d2 Bishop to
d1 first transferring the bishop to the
Queen side Knight to f3 Bishop to a for
now Knight - D - King e7 Bishop to f2
and Queen to g4 here Queen to f3 was
played stockfish offers an exchange of
Queens and we have Bishop to d1 now
attacking the Queen and here stockfish
captures that Queen captures Bishop
captures and in the end after 63 moves
we have an endgame opposite colored
bishops here and each player I mean both
alpha and E and
stockfish have a knight so the material
is equal but there is
the weakness of this a3 pawn so
stockfish decides to push a for with the
idea of pushing a5 breaking up this pawn
structure and then capturing and c5 with
the bishop but alpha doesn't allow it
nice to be 7 is played now even if
sawfish pushes the night we'll be
protecting the c5 pawn Knight the b1 and
we have a knife to a5 now attacking the
c4 pawn and as you can see it's it's
always good to have a dark square bishop
in place your own pawns and light
squares but now you sorry now you can't
defend the points that are on white
squares and it's interesting how far did
alpha look to see that this endgame was
winning for him or it so Bishop to e3
and it doesn't help to defend the pawn
which knighted in to simply Bishop to e2
and again you're losing this pawn so
after Knight a5 Bishop to e3 Knight
captures on c4 Bishop 2 c1
Bishop to d7 and Knight to c3 c6 now
King to G 1 C capture Sun d5e capture
Sun d5 and Bishop to a5 King to have to
Knight to d6 Bishop to e3 and now Knight
to e4 check here alpha forces an
exchange of knights
this has to be accepted Knight captures
Bishop captures and here we have an
opposite colored bishops endgame where
alpha is only a pawn up but this will be
this will be sufficient 85 we have B
captures on a5 Bishop captures on c5
King 37 now alpha has a free a passed
pawn that is ready to stroll down the
board d6 Bishop to f5 Bishop to e3 King
to c6
kingi 1 Kings to d5 King 32 and King to
e4 Bishop to b2 now and it doesn't help
you can't really stop the King from
approaching this point even if you play
King g3 King to f3 and there was no way
to stop looking from approaching it king
he for Bishop to b2 now can get for
Bishop to c1 King g3 King G - now King
sorry first a for King f1 and now King
characters on h4 king f2 now alpha it's
two points up and this is this is plenty
kingi for Bishop to a3 Bishop to d7
Bishop to c1 and King to f5 we have King
to e3 and now King to e6 and in this
position stockfish resigned the game
because there's really no point in
continuing it I will just show a
variation how simple it really is to end
this game for example Bishop to e3 you
have to protect the d6 pawn and now
simply H for stopping white from pushing
g3 King get three now f5 g3
simply push h3 King F to e for a king g1
now III Bishop to c5 attacking the pawn
I've simply to Bishop b4 stopping the
pond from queening and not simply a
three and the bishop cannot stop both
threats as if he captures one the other
one gets promoted so yeah this is the
game of all the of the tank it's it's a
shame they only showed 10 games played
by alpha zero and stop this is a this is
game number two but it's the seventh one
I'm showing you the second one where
alpha has the black pieces and it's very
interesting
so always when alpha has why today end
up playing the queen's indian defense
and of all the games we've seen where
alpha has the black pieces stockfish off
opens it with E 4 and alpha plays the
Berlin defense
so maybe maybe there is something to
this brilliant defense maybe we should
we should all learn from alpha so yeah
that was the game you'll requested it I
know it's a it's a very popular match so
I mean I'm interested in it as well you
don't really have to talk me into it but
yeah I would like to thank Stephane Dion
Stefan Dean for a contribution to my
channel think of what I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here I will make
both of them
alpha0 games also you can check all of
the games played by alpha zero and
starfish on a link in the description
below thank y'all for watching and I
will see you soon